>> We're at the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Alright, good morning.
And on behalf of the
Library of Congress welcome
to the 2010 National Book Festival.
We hope you have a wonderful day
celebrating books and reading
and the joy of reading right
here on the National Mall.
Before we begin I want to inform you
that the pavilion's
presentations today are being filmed
for the Library of
Congress's website.
So please be mindful of this.
If you have any problems you don't
have to stay but we hope you do
because this is going to be
a wonderful presentation.
And please do not sit on the
camera risers that are located
in the back of the pavilion.
Thank you very much.
Well once again it's
nice to see you all.
My name is Eun Yang.
And if you are up early
getting ready for work
or getting your kids
ready for school
or just having insomnia I
deliver the news in the morning,
if you turn on NBC 4;
so, good morning to you.
And I love books.
And I was an avid reader until I
had kids and now it's a fond memory.
I still try to read once in awhile.
My youngest is with me
and I apologize for that.
But the boys are in soccer
and you know you gotta
do the tag-team action.
[Background sound effects] But
thank you for your understanding.
Since this is the teens
and children's pavilion I figured
you parents would understand my
work life.
Thank you very much.
And I love this day because this is
the day when authors are rock stars
and they should be treated as such,
because they fill our imaginations
and take us away from our
current life and help us
to explore our imaginations and
other worlds in so many great ways.
Well our first author this
morning serves up exciting
and suspenseful thrillers that
take readers behind the scenes
of American politics.
Brad Meltzer wrote the number one
New York Times bestselling book,
The Book of Fate as well as the
bestsellers the 10th Justice,
Dead End, The First Council
and the Book of Lies.
He is the author of the
critically acclaimed comic book,
Justice League of America, woo hoo.
It won the Eisner award.
And he also the co-creator of
the TV show, Jack and Bobby,
obviously very impressive.
"So why is here today at the teens
and children's pavilion", you ask?
Well you can thank
his 8 year old son.
When his son was born Brad
wanted to write him a book
that would last a lifetime.
But as he started writing he
realized he didn't know enough
about fatherhood to teach his son
the life lessons he wanted to share.
So he went on a mission to write
about real-life heroes who've shown
strength, courage, perseverance
and kindness and the belief
that anything is possible.
And then tell their stories in
hopes they will guide his son
to become a good man and
perhaps change the world himself.
That labor of love resulted in
Brad's first non-fiction book.
A handpicked collection of
the best stories of heroism
from the Wright Brothers, Nelson
Mandela, Jim Henson, Harper Lee,
Rosa Parks and many, many more.
Heroes for My Son is a gift to
his child and to his readers;
ladies and gentleman Brad Meltzer.
[Applause]
>> My name is Suzanne Collins.
[Laughter] Come on,
when you come to speak
and everyone is the front row is
holding her book instead of mine,
like I'm not gonna make that joke.
[Laughter] So, here's
the story right.
I didn't know anything
about being a parent.
I thought I did, right.
Every parent in this audience knows
when that kid comes you think
you know what you're going to do,
but you don't know what
you're going to do.
I learned however from the
greatest parents of all time.
Because when my mother -- when
I went to Borders Headquarters
in Anne Arbor, Michigan they said,
"Guess where you're books
sell more than anywhere else?"
And I said, "Well obviously
New York City.
8 million New Yorker's
in one place you know."
They said, "Nope."
I said, "Washington, D.C. I
always right about Washington."
"No." The number one place where
by books sold was the Boca Raton,
Florida Borders, one mile
from a furniture store
where my mother used to work.
[Laughter] That means my mother
single-handedly beat 8 million
New Yorkers.
[Laughter] That's my mom's side.
My dad, this is true, my dad
in December had heart
surgery, open heart surgery.
Major surgery for him
and when you go
from open heart surgery the
difference is you've got
to go interview the doctors.
And you go and interview the doctors
and you don't just go, "Hey."
You know you gotta make sure you
like the guy, you know what kind
of person, you what kind
of procedure they're
going to do to you.
So he's go to see the
first doctor and he says --
you know he's really finely
dressed and his manicured hands
and he just looks all put together.
And he says, "I don't do the
full cut open your chest.
I do a small incision up here.
It's going to be completely
harmless.
I'm going to go in.
I'm not even going to
crack your rib cage.
You're going to be done in no time.
You're going to be out of
the hospital in a day."
We know he's lying to us, but
he's really put it together.
And he's like, "It's
a new procedure.
No one can do except me.
It's fantastic.
You're going to love it."
We go see another doctor.
And he says, "I do it
the old fashioned way.
I crack your chest open.
I have to pull you apart.
It's going to be a brutal recovery.
You could die."
Okay. And he says as he's saying
this, he looks down at the chart
and goes, "Oh wait,
Meltzer, Brad Meltzer."
I'm in there with him and he
goes, "I read your books."
I said, "Thanks."
And he goes on and he
says, "It's really going
to be a ruthless ordeal for you."
And so we leave and I look at
my dad and it's pretty clear
which doctor we need to pick right?
The first doctor is
all put together.
He's never lost anyone
on the table he told us.
And my dad says, "Well,
we found our man."
And I said, "Which one?"
And he says, "The second guy."
And I said, "Dad what
are you talking about?
It's going to be harder
and you could die.
And they crack your rib cage
and you're never gonna
get out of there."
And he says, "Yeah,
but he buys the books."
[Laughter] And I said, "You know,
found out if it's hardback
or paperback."
[Laughter] But the truth
was my dad actually did go
with the first doctor.
That is a true story.
I can't make it up.
So with those parents, I
embarked on parenthood myself.
And as you heard in the
introduction, eight years ago
at Sibley Hospital here in
Washington, D.C. my son was born.
And I came home.
I love telling this story here
because this is the hometown crowd.
I lived here for so long.
I had my kids here and I
thank you all for coming here.
This is obviously a very
personal place to be.
And I'm driving home from
Sibley, stuck at that red light
at the wonderful circle that
wraps around and you have to go
around twice because you
missed the turn hypothetically.
And as I'm at that red light I
remember looking up at the sky
at night and saying, "What kind
of man do I want my son to be?"
And it's a big moment right?
It's that moment when everything
in the world is possible.
That moment when you can dream
your child to be anything you want.
I'm not talking about famous or
wealthy, but to be a nice person,
to be kind, to be the
person who's nice
to everybody and everybody likes.
And I came home that night and I
said, "I'm going to write a book
that lasts his whole life."
And the truth was I knew nothing
about fatherhood, nothing at all.
And I started writing
rules for him to live by.
And I said one, be nice
to the fat kid in class.
And I started writing all these
rules you know one by one.
You know one day I'd
give him this book
and he'd think I was
indeed the greatest father.
And then a friend of mine
told me this amazing story
about the Wright Brothers.
He said every time the
Wright Brothers went
out to fly their plane, they
would bring enough materials
for multiple crashes.
That means every time they went out
they knew they were going to fail.
And they will crash and
rebuild and crash and rebuild
and that's why they took off.
And I said, "I love that story."
I want my son to hear that story.
I want my daughter
to hear that story.
I want them to know that
if they have perseverance
and if they work hard
and they have a plan
and they have a good side
order of stubbornness
that they can do anything
in this world.
And I said, "That's the
book I want to write."
Not a book of rules,
but a book of heroes.
And I said I just don't want
to write an obvious story.
We all know the obvious
story about everyone.
What I want to find was not just
stories about famous people,
but I wanted to find
moments we didn't know.
So, Thomas Jefferson is in the book,
but not because he wrote the
declaration of independence,
he's in the book because
he never took credit
for writing the declaration
while he was alive.
He never stood up and said, "Hey you
know that declaration you all know
and love, that was
me I wrote it, TJ."
I totally made that part up.
By the way I write fiction.
He didn't call himself TJ.
That's not historically accurate.
[Laughter] But I will tell you
that I love that story also right.
I love that story because I want my
son to learn that kind of humility.
Imagine a politician today
having that kind of humility.
A politician today would tattoo
the words, "I wrote the declaration
of independence" on their forehead.
Right, that's what they would do
if they did something like that.
And I said those are the
stories I need to find.
Not stories of just famous people,
but stories of what we're all
capable of on our very best days.
And so there are stories in
there of people you don't know.
There's a guy named Frank
Shankwitz [Assumed spelling] who's a
police officer.
And Frank Shankwitz found
out about a boy with leukemia
who also wanted to
be a police office.
So Shankwitz had a police
uniform made for the boy.
He had a little motorcycle
riding course made for the boy.
And then the boy went into a coma.
So Office Shankwitz goes to the
boy's hospital room and he pins
on little motorcycle wings on the
boy, at which point the boy wakes
up out of his coma and smiles.
And then he falls back
into the coma.
The boy eventually dies
and on the way home
from the funeral Officer Frank
Shankwitz, this police officer looks
at his buddy on the plane
and says, "You know,
we made that kid really
happy for just one day.
We should do that for other kids."
And that's how the Make A
Wish Foundation is born.
I didn't know that story
and I love that story too.
I want my son to hear that story.
I want my daughter
to hear that story.
And these are the things
that we're all capable of.
It's just the idea of what
you can do with one idea
when you share with somebody else.
So the book is set up very simply.
It's a one-page story
on the right-hand page,
one picture on the left.
And it has Jim Henson, Mr. Rogers,
Rosa Parks and Martin Luther King,
Jr. Now I will tell you, one of
my favorite moments was when I got
to share and I couldn't tell this
at the beginning of the book tour,
but I can tell it now because I got
to share the book with
my son, right.
This is the moment.
It's called Heroes for My Son
and I'm giving it to my son.
This is the moment when the
clouds are going to part.
The rainbows are going to
come from every direction.
I've waited nearly a decade
for this exact moment.
And so I go into his bedroom and I
wait until my other kids are asleep.
And we get on the bed and he
doesn't care about Rosa Parks.
He doesn't care about
Eleanor Roosevelt.
He wants to know where
the athletes are.
He likes sports.
So he flips through
the book really quickly
and he finds a guy
named Roberto Clemente.
And Roberto Clemente is
a guy who used to play --
one of the famous baseball players
for the Pittsburg Pirates, okay.
And I always tell my son
all the time I'm like,
"Just because you're a famous
athlete doesn't mean anything.
It doesn't make you a hero.
It just means you're good at sports.
Being a novelist on the bestseller
list doesn't mean anything.
It doesn't make you anyone.
It just means you can write.
And it just means your family
buys a lot of copies right?
Trust me on this one.
Trust me. So I'm reading
Roberto Clemente.
He's in the book not because
he was a great baseball player,
not because of the Gold
glove awards he won.
He's in it because he found out
about an earthquake in Nicaragua.
And Roberto Clemente wanted to get
so involved he sent
three plane loads of food
and medicine to Nicaragua.
All three plane loads were stolen.
They were confiscated.
And so he was so determined
to make sure
that the fourth plane gets
there he says, "I'm going to get
on the plane myself and
make sure it gets there."
And he gets on the plane
and the plane crashes
in the ocean killing everyone on
board including Roberto Clemente.
And then it says in the book
he's not a hero because he died.
He's a hero because of
why he got on board.
And so as I'm sharing this
I'm waiting for my son
to tell me how inspired
he is, what a genius I am
to produce this book for him.
And he looks at me and I feel
him shrinking him in my arms.
I can tell something's
wrong and he looks up at me
and he says, "Dad this is sad."
And now I'm terrified that
I've ruined everything right.
I blew it.
The book is not working
the way I wanted.
This is a disaster.
It's backfired in my face.
And so the next night
I put the book aside.
I put it on the side table.
I don't even bring it out.
And he races into the room and he
jumps up on the bed and he says
to me, "So who are we
going to read tonight?"
And I said, "Well what
about Roberto Clemente."
And he says, "I like him."
And I said, "Why?"
And he eventually said, "Because he
gave his life to save those people."
And I think we all know, for
those of us who are parents
that sometimes the greatest
moments in parenting are the moments
that are complete and
utter accidents.
And that's how it was
for me in that moment.
Everything worked out
exactly how I wanted
but in a way I never anticipated.
And it was this great beautiful
reward and the idea that that story
of generosity and perseverance
and kindness to strangers
and charity is twisted into my
son's chest is the greatest thing
in the whole world.
That's better than being
on any bestseller list,
except the hardcover
bestseller list.
[Laughter] And so I want to tell you
about the most important
hero in the book.
And the most important hero
in the book is my mother.
All due respect to George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson,
my mom is in the last
page of the book.
And I'll tell you my mom died
two years ago from breast cancer.
And it was the reason that I
really decided to finish the book.
I said, "You know what I'm
not saving the kind words
for the eulogy anymore."
I'm not going to wait my
whole life to give it to him.
I started really thinking
I gotta finish it.
And I couple years ago when I
was living here in Washington
and my second book came out, my
publisher actually shut down.
It was sold and I didn't
know if anybody was going
to take over my contract.
I was terrified because this was
the end of my writing career.
And I called my mom and I
said to her how scared I was
and my mom said, and I'll
never forget it, she said,
"I'd love you if you
were a garbage man."
And she wasn't taking
a crack at garbage men.
My uncle was a garbage man.
She was just saying, "I
don't care what you are.
I don't care what your job is.
I love you no matter what."
And every day that I sit down to
write I say those words to myself.
"I'd love you if you
were a garbage man",
just soaking in my
mom's love for me.
That's what I do every
morning before I get up.
Right before I sit down at my
writing table, that's my one ritual.
And I will tell you that
that's why she's my hero.
For you the most important hero
and heroes for my son is the
on the very last page, because
the very last page is blank.
And it says, "Your heroes picture
here and your heroes story here."
And I promise you that if you take
a picture of your mom or your dad
or your kids or your grandparents
or a military member of your family
or a teacher in your life and you
put their picture in this book
and you write one sentence
about what they've done for you
that would be the most beautiful
written page in heroes for my son.
It's a vital page and I
think that's what the book is
about is giving my son a
way to say, "Thank you.
Thank you for being my hero."
Give everyone a chance.
You know we are a country.
I think we all recognize
we are starving for heroes.
Look around it is tough
times out there.
And it is tough to find a
hero and that's what's vital
to me is finding that hero.
So this is my chance to
kind of bring it out.
So what I'd love to do more
importantly is take questions.
I always find that's
the best way rather
than have me lecture
for half an hour.
So ask any questions you want.
I write fiction.
I'll make up an answer.
It's fine.
[Laughter] Yes ma'am.
>> It's rather a statement.
I am so inspired by you when you
mention Roberto Clemente [Sound
effects] because I
am from Puerto Rico.
So thank you for make
Roberto a part of your book.
>> Thank you.
The question is you're awesome
for mentioning Roberto Clemente.
That is the best question
I've ever had.
[Laughter] Any more questions
that say like I am the best?
I am the greatest.
I am wonderful.
I will take those first.
Those are my favorite questions.
Thank you ma'am.
>> What was the most
inspiring story for you?
>> Yeah, the question was in doing
the research what was the most
inspiring story.
There was one beside my mom
and my grandfather who are
in the book there was
one that blew me away.
And it was Ann Sullivan.
And I had -- Helen Keller was
actually picked out for the book.
She was the one who was
supposed to be in the book.
Then I found out that everyone
knows the story of Helen Keller.
That's she's this woman who's
blind and deaf and supposedly dumb.
And everyone says,
"Forget this girl.
She's unteachable.
Give up on her."
And her teacher Ann Sullivan --
you know we all know the story.
Many people have seen the movie.
You know she writes
in her hand everyday
and that's how she learns to talk.
What I didn't also know at that time
was that there was no Braille books.
There were no Braille
books for her to read.
So the only way she could read her
textbooks was that her teacher,
Ann Sullivan, would everyday finger
write in her hands every book.
Five hours every day
just finger writing
in her hand what everything
said in the book.
At the same time, Ann Sullivan's
own eyesight was fading.
And her doctor said to
her, "If you keep reading
to this girl you are going to
risk going blind yourself."
And Ann Sullivan said,
"I don't care."
And she kept reading to Helen Keller
and Helen Keller graduated
from Radcliff cum laude.
And as someone who had a
teacher change my life, I just --
I mean I read that story and that
was gasoline to me for months.
I still, you know when I get down
and I'm thinking it's really hard,
I read that story and
it's just fantastic to me.
I love that someone like that
existed on this planet with us.
Yes.
>> [Inaudible background question]
>> Yeah, the question is why
do you hate your daughter?
[Laughter] So the question is
what about heroes for my daughter.
Yes, I am not stupid.
I made when deal when I
signed the deal for this book.
I said there has to
be a two-book deal.
And they said, "Why?"
And I said, "You clearly
have never met my daughter."
[Laughter] Now my daughter, for
those of you who have met her,
because there a few I see here.
She comes into my office every day
and says, "Where's my book dad?"
[Laughter] "When are you going
to be done with my book?"
She drives me harder
than my own editor.
I always knew I was going to
do a book for her as well.
I certainly saved people for her.
I saved Ann Frank for her.
I saved certain people that
I knew had to be in her book
and it's amazing to work
on because it's the same
and I treat them the
same, but it's different.
As anyone who has a son and
daughter knows, it just is.
And I know that my daughter's life,
no matter how idealistic I want
to be about this world
is going to be different
than my son's in experience.
And so the lessons I'm picking, I
thought there would be no difference
at all and I wanted to say,
"Nope you know I treat
them exactly the same."
You know I bought wood
blocks for my kid.
I didn't buy Barbies.
I didn't buy cars.
My son of course loves cars
and my daughter loves Barbies.
Like you can't control some
things, and I can't control the fact
that I'm picking different
heroes for her
and in a strange way,
many of the same heroes.
The other question, in terms
of what else am I working on,
there is a new thriller coming out
in January called The Inner Circle.
That takes place in Washington,
D.C. It's at the National Archives.
It is the beginning of a
series character for me,
the first series I've ever done.
And I can't wait for it to come out.
I can't wait to share it.
It's the first book in four years
I've done back in Washington.
Everyone knows that has come
and seen me speak here before,
I always steal the physical
descriptions of characters
from when I ride the Metro here and
so if you see yourself in the book,
it is because I stole your face.
That is absolutely true.
And the other thing we're working
on, if you look in either November
or December it will be on the air.
And if you look in
our Facebook page,
if you go to our Facebook
page, we're launching a TV show
on the History Channel and it is
called Brad Meltzer's Decoded.
It is the greatest
title of all time to me.
And as I told my wife the other day,
"You know honey, what are we having
for Brad Meltzer's
dinner tonight [Laughter]
because yesterday we had Brad
Meltzer's chicken and tonight I'd
like to have Brad Meltzer's pasta."
But what this show is is it lets
me take all the things that I do
in my thrillers and try and find
the real answers in real life.
So one of the episodes in
1792 when the first piece
of the White House was put down, the
very first cornerstone was put down,
within 24 hours it
supposedly disappeared.
For 200 years now nobody
has been able to find it.
No one knows where the first
piece of the White House is.
And Harry Truman went looking for
it when he redid the White House.
And Barbara Bush went looking for it
when they celebrated the
anniversary celebration.
Nobody knows where it is and
that's an episode of decoded
that we're going to try
and find the answer.
So that's basically
what's going to be working
on from there those three things.
Yes sir.
>> I don't have a question,
I have an inspiration.
>> Yes please.
>> You told my wife and wrote in
a book, "No is not an option."
And she finished a book and
I want to give it to you.
>> That's awesome.
Yes please.
[Applause] Let me tell you
something, every time I speak,
when they ask where you got
started I tell one story.
And I didn't tell it here
because I figured you know I want
to tell something new and
not do the same thing.
But every time I got
-- I got what I got
when I wrote my first
book, 24 rejection letters.
Now there were to be clear
only 20 publishers at that time
and I got 24 rejection letters.
That means some people
are writing you twice
to make sure you get the point.
[Laughter] And I remember I
was on the phone here in D.C.
when I got my 23rd and
24th rejection letter.
My agent called me up
and said, "Sorry kiddo."
I'll never forget it.
I was looking at the fire station
across from the Ritz
Carlton downtown on M Street
and every time I pass it.
I actually have a picture
on my phone of it
and whenever I think I'm getting
too big or I'm thinking --
like I'm too much of a
hotshot, I look at that picture
and remember what its
like to have nothing,
to have nothing but rejection.
And every time I tell that story
someone comes up to me afterwards
and says, "I'm working on a book
and that means something to you."
But never in over a decade has
anyone come and given me a book
after they heard that
talk, so thank you.
I appreciate that.
[Applause] And congratulations
that's a big deal.
And so every person here, every
single person here who's working
on a book, please, please, please
don't let anyone tell you no.
That is a vital, vital lesson.
Other questions that
tell me how awesome I am?
[Laughter] Yes.
>> [Inaudible background question]
>> Yes, the question is are
there any current heroes?
Or did you just pick the dead ones.
[Laughter] And you
know what there are.
And I think that's what I love
the most about this book is
that there are heroes everywhere.
There's a guy named Andy Miyares
from Florida who's a
special Olympics swimmer.
And when he was born they said he
wasn't going to walk for a couple
of years and he wound
up doing it much faster.
By 9 months he wound up moving
and being able to crawl.
They thought it was going
to take him years to do it.
And they didn't think he could learn
and his parents put him in the pool
and he learned how to
count by swimming laps.
He loved to swim.
And he would count one, two, three,
four and even in the special
Olympics he's considered
an underdog.
He basically has the hands a
little like a five year old.
He has these tiny little hands.
He's small.
He's petite.
Even in the special Olympics,
think about that for a minute.
He's considered the underdog.
But he has something like six
world records and he lives
in Florida, not far from me.
And I love that that
guy is there and so many
of us don't know about him.
There's also things like Team Hoyt.
I don't know if you know Team Hoyt.
But when Dick and Judy when their
son was born he was also told --
he was so severely disabled.
Excuse me.
He was so severely disabled
that they told them you
have to put him away.
Put him in an institution.
No one will care about this kid.
He's going to amount to nothing.
He'll never understand you.
And his parents wouldn't
give up on him.
They took him everywhere.
They would drag him
in the wheelchair.
They would take him swimming.
They would do whatever they did
and there was a charity race
for a boy who had been paralyzed.
And the young son Rick
said, "You know what,
we should run in that race
dad just to show that kid
that you shouldn't give up and
anything is still possible."
And so the dad takes
his son and pushes him
in the wheelchair and
runs in the race.
And when he runs in the race you
know he needs a computer to speak
and it took him until his teens
before he spoke his first sentence.
And you know he typed that on a
computer using his eyes to type.
And he finally said, "Go
Bruins" was his first sentence.
[Laughter] At least he
wasn't a Yankee fan.
And basically he runs in the
race and he finishes the race
and he says, "Dad, when
I'm with you it feels
like my disability disappears."
And the dad continues
to run in marathons.
He pushes his son.
He runs in Iron men.
He swims. He ties a rope
around his chest and swims
with his boy behind him
tugging him the entire way.
And to this day the
younger son can't walk,
but with his father
these two men fly.
I love that story.
They still run races.
They sent me a card and said,
"Thanks for putting
me in your book."
And I was like, "Are you kidding me.
That was the easiest part."
And I just love that people
like that are still here
and I think we just -- you know
it's so easy to focus on the bad
and I'm not saying we should
all say everything's roses
and everything's wonderful,
but don't forget how much
good there is out there.
Don't forget the heroes are there.
And most important, this
is why I saved it for last.
Don't forget to thank them.
So with that said let me say the
most important thing I will say
today and that is, "Thank you!"
Thank you for coming year
after year and supporting me.
[Applause] It means more than
you will ever, ever know.
Thanks very much.
[Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.